>>> YOU KNOW, A LOT OF
GRADUATING SENIORS ARE FEELING
EXTRA CELEBRATORY THIS YEAR
AFTER ENDURING MONTHS OF VIRTUAL
LEARNING, BUT MY NEXT GUEST USED
HER CAP AND GOWN MOMENT TO MAKE
A MAJOR STATEMENT, SHE TOSSED
OUT A PREAPPROVED SPEECH TO
CRITICIZE A NEW TEXAS LAW THAT
BANS ABORTIONS AFTER A FETAL
HEARTBEAT CAN BE DETECTED AS
EARLY AS SIX WEEKS.
>> TODAY I WAS GOING TO TALK
ABOUT TV AND MEDIA AND CONTENT
BECAUSE IT'S SOMETHING THAT IS
VERY IMPORTANT TO ME, HOWEVER
UNDER LIGHT OF RESENT EVENTS, IT
FEELS WRONG TO TALK ABOUT
ANYTHING OTHER THAN WHAT IS
CURRENTLY AFFECTING ME.
SIX WEEKS IS ALL THEY GET.
MOST OF THEM DON'T REALIZE THEY
ARE PREGNANT BY SIX WEEKS, AND
BEFORE THEY HAVE A CHANCE TO
DECIDE IF THEY ARE EMOTIONALLY,
PHYSICALLY AND FINANCIALLY AND
STABLE ENOUGH TO CARRY OUT A
FULL-TERM PREGNANCY, BEFORE THEY
CAN GET A CHANCE TO TAKE ON THE
RESPONSIBILITY TO TAKE ON HUMAN
IN THE WORLD, THAT DECISION IS
MADE BY A STRANGER, THAT
DECISION THAT WILL AFFECT THEM
FOR THE REST OF THEIR LIVES IS
MADE BY A STRANGER, AND I HAVE
DREAMS, HOPES AND AMBITIONS AND
EVERY TKPGIRL GRADUATING TODAY
DOES, AND WITHOUT OUR CONTROL
OVER THAT FUTURE HAS BEEN
STRIPPED AWAY FROM US.
>> NOW, THERE WERE HUGE APPLAUSE
FROM HER FELLOW STUDENTS,
GETTING PRAISE ON SOCIAL MEDIA
AND EVEN GETTING THE ATTENTION
OF HILLARY CLINTON WHO SAID THIS
TOOK GUTS.
PAXTON SMITH IS WITH ME NOW.
THIS CERTAINLY DID TAKE GUTS.
I READ THAT YOU TYPICALLY DON'T
LIKE TO SHARE POLITICAL OR
CONTROVERSIAL OPINIONS.
WHY DID YOU DECIDE TO TALK ABOUT
THIS?
>> I FELT LIKE REPRODUCTIVE
RIGHTS WERE SO IMPORTANT AND
RIGHT NOW THEY ARE CURRENTLY
UNDER ATTACK FROM SO MANY
DIFFERENT STATES WITH PASSING OF
LEGISLATION THAT IS RESTRICTING
ABORTIONS ALL OVER THIS -- OVER
THE COUNTRY, AND I FELT LIKE IT
WAS CRUCIAL THAT I USED MY
PLATFORM TO REACH PEOPLE WHO
WERE NEUTRAL ABOUT THE TOPIC OR
DIDN'T AGREE WITH ME ON THE
TOPIC TO SPREAD THE MESSAGE THIS
WAS NOT OKAY.
>> DID ANYBODY KNOW THIS WAS
GOING TO HAPPEN, AND I NOTE
ORGANIZERS AND ADMINISTRATORS
DIDN'T, BUT DID YOU TELL YOUR
FAMILY OR FRIENDS?
>> I ONLY TOLD MY PARENTS.
>> WHAT DID THEY TELL YOU?
>> AT FIRST THEY WERE A LITTLE
APPREHENSIVE, AND IT'S A VERY
CONTROVERSIAL TOPIC AND IT'S
SCARY TO PUT YOUR FACE ON THAT
TOPIC, BUT THEY WERE SUPPORTIVE
AFTER ABOUT A DAY.
>> TOOK THEM A DAY TO BE
SUPPORTIVE.
OKAY.
>> YES.
>> SO I WATCHED THE ENTIRE
SECTION OF THE GRADUATION
CEREMONY.
YOU TALKED FOR ABOUT TWO AND A
HALF MINUTES, AND THE ORGANIZERS
AND ADMINISTRATORS DID NOT CUT
YOUR MIC, AND THEY LET YOU
FINISH AND WE HEARD THE
APPLAUSE.
WAS THERE A RESPONSE AFTERWARDS?
>> AFTERWARDS THEY WERE
SUPPORTIVE AND CONGRESS LaTORRE,
HOWEVER WHEN I DID MAKE MY WAY
BACK TO THE STAGE, A COUPLE
PEOPLE -- I THINK THEY WERE
WORKING FOR THE SCHOOL OR
HELPING TO RUN THE EVENT AND I
AM NOT SURE HOW THEY WERE
AFFILIATED WITH THE SCHOOL, AND
THEY SAID THEY WERE CONSIDERING
HOLDING MY DIPLOMA, AND THAT DID
NOT HAPPEN.
>> YOU HAVE YOUR DIPLOMA?
>> YES.
>> YOU SEEMED NERVOUS AS YOU
DISCUSSED IT, AND I WANT YOU TO
TAKE LITTLE MORE TIME OF HOW
THIS FEELS WHEN IT COMES TO THE
DATE WHEN THIS LAW IS ENACTED?
>> HOW IT FEELS.
IT FEELS TERRIBLE.
IT FEELS UNREAL LIKE THIS COULD
BE A DYSTOPIAN NOVEL THAT WOMEN
DON'T HAVE THAT CONTROL OVER
THEIR BODY, AND IT'S REALLY
UPSETTING TO ME.
>> YOU'RE GOING TO STUDY MUSIC,
I READ.
IS THAT CORRECT?
>> YES.
MOST LIKELY.
>> IS THERE ACTIVISM IN YOUR
FUTURE, OR A POLITICAL FUTURE
FOR YOU AS WELL?
>> POTENTIALLY.
I'M WAITING TO SEE HOW THINGS
GO.
I WILL PLAY IT BY EAR AND SEE
WHAT OPPORTUNITIES ARE OPEN TO
ME IN AUSTIN, AND SEE IF THERE'S
SOMETHING THAT I FEEL JUST AS
STRONGLY ABOUT OR IF THIS
CONTINUES TO BE AN ISSUE I WILL
CONTINUE TO SPEAK OUT ABOUT
THIS.
BUT WHEN I GET TO AUSTIN, I WILL
MAKE A GAME PLAN AND I CAN LET
YOU GUYS KNOW.
>> WHAT DID YOU FEEL WHEN YOU
SAW THAT TWEET FROM SECRETARY
CLINTON?
>> I WAS SHOCKED.
I WAS -- I WAS SHOCKED.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
YOUR WORDS ARE RESONATING ONLINE
AND I KNOW YOU ARE GETTING A LOT
OF REACTION.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME.
>> THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME.
>> SURE.
>> I MEAN, JUST THINKING ABOUT
HOW NERVE-RACKING THAT MUST HAVE
BEEN FOR HER, BECAUSE SHE DIDN'T
KNOW SHE WAS GOING TO GET
APPLAUSE FROM CLASSMATES AND
FROM THE GUESTS.
IT COULD HAVE GONE ANY WAY.
>> AT THAT AGE TO STEP OUT ON
THAT PLATFORM ON THAT ISSUE, A